certain medical records for former las  vegas raider henry ruggs will be kept  private this morning ruggs did not  appear in court with his attorneys but  his attorneys obviously were there now  prosecutors say ruggs was driving drunk  with his girlfriend more than 150 miles  an hour when he crashed into another car  killing that driver today the judge  ruled only blood test results can be  used in court the judge is also limiting  testimony from medical staff to only  authenticate the records nothing else an  attorney for ruggs's girlfriend who was  also in the car at the time asked to  limit the release of her medical records  as well  my ruling yesterday was the blood test  results would be released  in addition to the  authentication of the medical records  and  nothing to do with conversations or  treatment as to any patient doctor  relationship  ruggs's next court appearance is january  6 at 9 30 a preliminary hearing  scheduled for march